Барселона посідає третє місце в Європі за рівнем надходжень від туризму - після Лондона і Парижа.
Відпочивальники залишають тут близько 17 мільярдів євро на рік. Тут налічують в середньому
30 мільйонів ночівель щороку. Від туризму залежить робота сотень тисяч каталонців:
у ресторанах, готелях, в торгівлі. Після терактів минулого тижня місцеві бояться, що туристи
почнуть оминати місто. DW проаналізувала, як терористичні атаки вплинули на туризм в інших туристичних центрах.
Після нападів у Парижі наприкінці 2015-го кількість туристів спершу скоротилася. Передусім за рахунок
громадян США, Японії та Китаю, які почали оминати Францію. 2016 року французька столиця
недорахувалася півтора мільйона гостей - майже на 5 відсотків менше. Але така тенденція
була нетривалою. Цьогоріч потік туристів відновився.
Вибухи в Брюсселі у березні 2016-го і зокрема напад на міжнародний аеропорт, внаслідок чого загинули
три десятки людей, стали відчутними для місцевих готельє. Заповнюваність готелів
у бельгійській столиці впала до 57-ми відсотків. Попит відновився лише через рік.
Тим часом наїзд вантажівки на різдвяний ярмарок у грудні 2016-го на кількість туристів у німецькій
столиці майже не вплинула. У перші три місяці 2017-го до Берліна приїхали навіть на 15% більше туристів
з Китаю та на шість відсотків більше зі США - країн, громадяни яких дуже уважні до питань безпеки.
У 2015-му через теракти у Тунісі загинуло понад 60 іноземців. Бронювання впали на 70 відсотків.
Для економіки країни, яка залежить від туризму, це мало катастрофічні наслідки. У подібній ситуації
опинилася загалом вся Північна Африка - зокрема Єгипет та Марокко. Через терористичні
напади та політичну нестабільність цілий регіон потерпає від відтоку туризму.
Загалом експерти роблять висновок, що відтік туристів помітний зазвичай лише у перші місяці після теракту.
Якщо ситуація в обраній для відпустки країні в цілому здається їм безпечною,
потік відпочивальників доволі швидко відновлюється. На бульварі Ла Рамбла в Барселоні,
де внаслідок теракту загинули тринадцять людей, уже наступного дня знову було багато людей.